no opposite of what you do
[Music]
what a cheeky thing g'day i'm abc
sciences nature nerd ann
jones we've got plenty of deadly animals
here in australia
now it's time to look all around the
world
[Music]
i'm going to review the best videos on
the internet
from lightning fast assassins
to clever little criminals i hate you
i'm also going to speak to the luckiest
people in the world
who found themselves face to face with
deadly animals
i sprayed it out of it with bear spray
to discover which of these five land
animals
are truly deadly
first up bears they're found on almost
every continent
but how common are bear attacks on
humans and how can we avoid
being ambushed oh
look at those birds wait look at the
bears
this looks like it's in the forest in
finland
there are apparently about 2 000 bears
in finland and they're actually really
important in finnish culture they've got
hundreds of words that describe their
bears
oh head down is forward holy crap
they're big
they can reach up to like two meters
it's taller than your average human
they weigh something like maybe 350
kilograms
oh the strength
like they can break the spine of a prey
item by using their paw
really see like the fur shaking and the
fat stores that they're getting ready
for their their winter
as they're wrestling with each other
over probably
territory or food or maybe a female
makes you think differently about teddy
bears doesn't it
this is fascinating how it seems to be
using trees to put a tree
in between itself and the aggressor
it doesn't seem to want to turn its back
though does it
and that indeed is one of the pieces of
information that you receive is always
keep an eye on them and in fact try and
move sideways
god whoever got that clip is amazing
[Music]
judging by the music i'm saying it's
[Music]
america
she have cubs i think that that looks
like
like a black bear i think
so that's their camera she spotted him
she was just protecting her cubs it's a
natural thing to do
to want to protect your genetic legacy
and that's essentially what she was
doing
especially if she is a black bear
it's really unusual for them to be
aggressive they're actually
very timid and would much prefer to eat
you know
fruits and berries they really aren't
going for large prey items like a human
did he cut himself i'm like i'm like
we're fine
he's like no we're not yeah
life sucks in bear country just had a
grizzly with two cubs
about 80 yards and uh
i sprayed it out of her with bear spray
so in north america every year there's
something like
11 attacks on humans and not all of
those are fatal
she got my head good i don't know what's
under my head wow
my ear you can see a bit of skin my arm
i just walked out three miles and i go
to the hospital those guys
were incredibly lucky both to see the
bear and to survive
their attack and i spoke to another
lucky survivor
nick was attacked near his home in
wyoming in the united states
and he says that even though it was
terrifying he really doesn't blame the
bear
just as i stepped around i saw a sow
grizzly bear with two
little bitty cups and i
you know i just said uh-oh
took her about two and a half seconds to
get on me
and the first thing she did was reach up
and bite half my face off
bit through my hand if you bit through
my knee
he bit my scalp and peeled it and right
then i thought
yeah i thought yeah this could be it
it's probably just 15 or 20 seconds
seemed like an hour and then she left i
don't think her intent was
ever too you know i'm just gonna kill
her she just wanted me neutralized
she wanted me to be not a threat to her
cubs
he wasn't a rogue bearer out there
trying to
take out humans this was my fault so i
think that anybody who goes out
into the back country here is
prepared understand what you're doing
where you're going
look for signs take and know how to use
bear spray because
it doesn't do you any good if it's still
on your belt nick's attitude
is really impressive to me to understand
that uh that he was in her home and she
was doing what was natural
and that's the thing when you're on bear
country you should have bear spray you
should be prepared but what happens if
you're in your backyard
[Music]
i like that he's talking to it i don't
know what he's saying like
[Laughter]
he's not shouting at it when the bear is
in an aggressive posture
shouting in general is not recommended
because especially for brown bears it
could be interpreted as aggression and
actually make them more aggressive
towards you
this one turned out all right what
looks like he's sort of trying to call
the bears bluff
surely there's a part of him that he's
scared right but i seen his he's acting
like he isn't scared and that's the
point
what he's doing is acting like he's big
and scary so that the bear
thinks oh i better not take him on and
it's easier to
get out of here
[Music]
bears are obviously extremely dangerous
and could kill you
it's important that when you're in bear
country you should always be prepared
for an encounter with a bear
you should never approach a bear
particularly cubs
because that means a mama bears nearby
and on top of that
keep your rubbish locked away
leopards cute as cubs lethal as adults
[Music]
[Applause]
it's got a little tummy i wonder if it's
a mother
what an incredible animal hey those
spots
are actually called rosettes and they're
babies oh my god that's bringing tears
to my eyes it's so beautiful
they're really young
oh the little piece of meow
see how close together the spots are
when they're little that's also to help
with
camouflage darker when they're little
and they sort of spread out as they get
older the spots are actually in a
pattern that is unique to that
individual like a fingerprint
that was so cute oh my god
so this is very cool because the second
leopard the one that's on all fours
is stalking
see how it puts its feet down so quietly
and that's their hunting strategy they
stalk up as close as they can
and then they use those powerful legs to
do a big
pounce
[Applause]
they are sort of solitary animals right
and they're territorial so
it appears as if one of them is telling
the other
to bugger off get out of my territory
is that just leopard sounds off in the
distance i could watch cat videos all
day
to be fair
that a baboon in the background an
impala
that impala should have listened to
those baboons
see how quickly it stopped fighting like
i mean that's a really efficient kill
bam yeah always ready
they latch on with those huge claws and
then they clamp down
with their teeth in the jugular area
they really love this ambush style
killing they're not
cheaters they're not great ones to do a
big long chase
they much prefer to have a kill that
doesn't involve them running too much
this looks like we're in india
this is sort of common leopards
routinely turn up
in villages and even cities like mumbai
in
india it's what we call human wildlife
conflict
that's where habitat is being used and
changed by humans
it also just speaks to the amount of
people and the encroachment
into leopard habitat
my god my god
not only is the leopard an incredible
jumper they're quick
they can run almost 60 k's an hour
they're so strong they can jump
something like six meters
in length in one big leap and they can
also jump
three meters straight up
imagine being on your way to work and
being confronted by this
and on the way to work this morning i
saw kangaroos
okay someone's he's gone for the dog
leopards have incredible vision at night
they can see
up to seven times better than humans
when you see leopards hunting pets it's
pretty clear
that they have adapted to our human-made
environments
but in india in mumbai for example you
could say that leopards are actually
doing a favor for humans
gee that guy did a good job to get up
and into
that truck away from the leopard
that was hanging onto his leg
[Applause]
this shows just how important apex
predators are in an ecosystem
when you've got something like 95 000
stray dogs
in a place like mumbai and they are
potentially rabies
carriers now there's something like 21
deaths a year from rabies in the human
population
from dog bites so they did some research
and found that the leopards that live in
mumbai and surrounds
actually eat something like 40 of their
whole diet
wild dogs you start to see
that leopards could become key to
controlling rabies
yes it's obvious right leopards are
dangerous to humans
more than that humans are dangerous to
lipids
we're the ones that have squeezed them
out of their habitats
and that's why they're coming into ours
so if you visit
leopard habitat by choice know the risks
it's your responsibility not the
leopards
[Music]
raccoons bandit markings have made them
the subject of songs and cartoons but
there's a lot more than just a cute
animal to this story
well actually their latin name is
procyon lotor that translates as trash
pandas
all right you can do it you can do it
that was pretty cute i mean they're not
necessarily known for being super agile
but they are persistent and intelligent
so they've adapted so well to living in
human environments they'll even
den in places like abandoned buildings
or even
in roofs
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
city eat too much trash
look i said that they were supremely
adapted to human conditions but i'm not
so sure now look at that silly thing
human food isn't really meant for
animals a lot of what we eat isn't even
meant for us
look they find it difficult to
distinguish between rappers and things
like that so they'll probably eat the
whole thing and then you'll make them
sick
and on top of that they can't
distinguish between what's good for them
and what isn't it's all just
awesome calories oh you [ __ ] this
house up good didn't you
i was looking for breakfast cereal
[Music]
is it eating the plaster or is he giving
it something to none
it could also be denning in the attic
the female can have like
one seven little cubs and actually they
don't
come fully independent until sometimes
like a full
12 months well it looks like he's
completely
destroyed my kitchen so this guy might
be living with raccoons for
quite some time how far can you reach
his own fault he's feeding him like
freeze ride strawberries or something
their hands are incredibly dexterous
unlike us they don't have opposable
thumbs i've only got fingers on each
hand
so to actually pick up anything she has
to use both
of her pores to get a handful
kitty oh that's a raccoon mum you'd see
her nipples
so she's going to be hungry and extra
bold
they've got really long fingers you can
see them as she's scooping up the kibble
they're really sensitive like 10 times
more sensitive than our fingers are
and one of the reasons that she's
putting the kibble
in the water
is because it increases the sensitivity
of her feelings so that she can feel
what she's eating ah
wow she's always bipedal there right i
mean that's adorable it also
shows how bold they can be especially
when they've got young to feed
and how close they're going to come to
you and your pets
so they're cute and crafty little fellas
but what makes them so dangerous
[Music]
i want to pick out shard or something no
he's got rabies
the poor little thing it just must be
such a horrible horrible thing to happen
so discharged from the mouth that's
where that foaming at the mouth
uh idea of rabies comes from and spasms
funny posture you should
really never approach raccoons because
they are
potentially carriers of rabies
rabies if untreated is 100
fatal
so the poor rabid raccoons make it onto
our deadly list
but it's on a technicality and if you
don't want to open your door to this
then seal up the house lock away your
food and do
not feed raccoons
[Music]
we all know monkeys can be a bit cheeky
we've heard stories about that but
are they actually man killers
unusual to see macaques in england but
there you go
they're known for being curious stealing
things
making sure that there's no food in the
uh what did they ha
they got someone's toy
primates in general are pretty amazing
they've got an opposable thumb and that
means that they can actually
touch the face of the thumb onto their
other digits
rather than onto the side and it's all
because of a special little joint that's
in the thumb
we've got it too on top of that they
obviously have big brains we talk about
this all the time our closest relatives
oh
colour vision just like us and sense of
fun
so it looks like we're at some sort of
temple maybe in china
clearly a tourist attraction how do you
do something do something
got it what'd you get mate yes went for
the object of high value
what a cheeky thing
so there's some research that indicates
that at some tourist
temples the monkeys actually undertake
this strategy they called
rob and barter where they steal
an object of high value that isn't food
and then use it to barter with the
person who owns that object to get food
so they steal your phone and then if you
give them a packet of peanuts they'll
give you your phone back
incredible there's even evidence to
suggest they're actually passing it down
and learning from each other generation
to generation
and that is what we call cultural
transmission it's
really important thing to hear that
these monkeys have
culture
and and an iphone 7.
i know he's an old fella oh your bugger
that's horrible it's what the hell are
they doing taking running kicks at
people like
ninjas i mean monkeys are terrifying for
so many reasons and now that we know
that they pick on the aged
i wonder if it's actually to try and
impress each other because
saying how powerful you are and how
impressive you are
is a way to move up the monkey ranks
[Music]
that's terrifying
probably just going to try to go for a
cup of tea or something or bugger
maybe when he went in that doorway he
actually startled a monkey
now these monkeys live in big troops and
they have a really
tightly knit social structure so when
one monkey is scared and screams the
other will come to their aid
and the other monkeys sort of pile on to
try and get rid of the threat
what do we got here oh okay
[Applause]
yeah nature is rough nature is
rough you wouldn't expect right to see
monkeys
on a how deadly list but actually
they are pretty murderous just not
towards humans
it's often towards each other
he's showing who is dominant in the
context of of a play time
so that's a male monkey a mature monkey
who's somewhere up in the top
of the troop and these sorts of
male monkeys have been witnessed killing
each other and also
killing young and they generally do that
to the young
of other males this is a reproductive
strategy as soon
as you get rid of the female's child
she'll probably come back into yeastress
again and that means that
she can have your child yeah spit icky
not gonna lie but that's just how
monkeys roll
[Music]
they're really complex creatures
incredibly
intelligent and we have so much to learn
about them and ourselves by watching
their behaviours
[Music]
human impacts on the environment mean
that snakes are coming closer and closer
into our cities
and it turns out that humans they really
don't know how to act
[Music]
it's a myth that snakes don't actually
need to drink snakes do
like to drink so they might be coming in
to find
water
[Applause]
australians are going to give me a heart
attack
just leave them alone and in fact around
your house
is probably perfect snake habitat
they've got water
they've got access to shelter they've
got access to food
mice yeah is it a recording
is it recording i can't even see it
here we have a big snake ah down there
yes see it's flattened itself out a
little bit so it's feeling a bit
threatened oh that is a biggie
they're huge man they do get to about
2.4 meters i can't see it
come out here no
no opposite of what you do stand here
and look come over here and watch
the more movement like you know the
potentially
more threatened the snake is going to
feel and also you know putting your
children
in the line of fire stay out there and
keep your eye on it
if you're going to run into a deadly
snake in australia
it's probably going to be an eastern
brown snake
because they're pretty common and they
live where people live
near or in your shopping centres oh my
god father
around your homes in our suburbs and
cities
for such a beautiful snake it's pretty
unfortunate that brown snakes
are responsible for most of the
snakebite deaths that happen
in australia
it's really hard to stop that reaction
from in yourself of panic
but it will often heighten the situation
[Music]
that kid did the best job
[Laughter]
such a beautiful animal like i am scared
of them
but the way they move is just so
mesmerizing
[Music]
so the stats are that around the world
every year there are one million
venomous snake bites
in fact in india every year it's thought
that there are 10
000 people that die from snake bites
we have nowhere near that sort of number
in australia and
on top of that we've got great access to
anti-venoms and
health services and that goes a long way
to surviving snake bites
[Music]
and that is a snake catcher with a moon
boot on
bless australia you can see the snake's
tongue coming in and out of its mouth
and what it's actually doing with that
tongue
is smelling in a sense the fork tongue
of a snake is actually used to give
two points of sensitivity in front of
the snake
if it goes out and the left one hits the
smell of a rat
it knows to go left and that's one of
the ways that snakes find their way
through the environment
so the average striking distance is
something like 34
centimeters maybe a foot
and they can strike in point one of a
second
that's really fast have a cracker this
is their defense
i'm in her space she's scared of me oh
if i stay still and i pose is no threat
to her
she'll start to back off spot on snakes
generally don't chase you it's not in
their biological interest to do so
if i start moving again and my shadow
moves look at her
she's definitely so that is sort of the
second stage
of what you would call snake offense
the first stage the brown snake will
make itself pretty flat
but its head won't be so far off the
ground it'll be
maybe like this makes itself flat to
make itself look bigger and more
powerful
that's saying i'm really not very happy
then when they go into that s posture
and ready to strike it is actually
slower in its strike but way more
accurate so it will definitely get you
if it's in that position
she's got all this bush to live in and
oh
sorry i got it darling
so we'll let her go on her way it was a
magnificent demonstration
of the fact that the steak really
doesn't want to bite you it doesn't want
to eat you it doesn't want to escalate
things
lots of snake bites that occur in
australia occur
because a human is harassing the snake
in some way
so the best thing to do is leave the
snake alone
give it space and if you're out bush
walking
try not to sneak up on snakes that means
use your bush walking boots to make a
little bit of a clump as you go along
[Music]
[Applause]
so there you have it that's some of the
world's most
deadly land animals and sure we don't
really want to get
too close to them but we can admire them
from afar
for their amazing physiology their
incredible ingenuity and their
adaptability
all in the effort to live another day
catch you next time
[Music]
hey thanks for watching and if you liked
this video
then stick around and subscribe because
we have plenty more where this comes
from in fact we upload a new
video every single week so i'll see you
then